johnny depp
aylin a-list hollywood actor we're going
to go see some of his movies that he's
that he's done
we're going to compare that to
amber heard's movies that she's done
let's just start with
let's start with hers
okay okay
these are the best movies that amber
heard has ever done
okay is that johnny in the living room
she's done aquaman in 2018
she's done the rum diary in 2011 where
she met johnny depp
she's i guess drive angry 2011. and look
at all her people
look at all her pre-production she's
about to work she's about to work bro
she's in
she was so she was in the new aquaman
that's okay post-production and now
she's already in pre-production first
dude she's a hot commodity bro well
she's gonna sell tickets keep going she
was in the stand that's a tv mini series
aquaman was aquaman pretty big guys yeah
yeah yeah okay aquaman was big justice
league was pretty big justice league was
pretty big
magic mike
she was in magic mike xxl not the
original the adderall diaries the
adderall guys that's like the draw okay
i want to say she was in um
pineapple express though she was in
zombieland pineapple express right here
yeah pull up a picture of young
amber heard pineapple express that's the
first time i saw her and i was like
she's uh who's that yeah she's cute she
was also in that fight movie with that
really handsome actor which one uh
images oh wow she was dude look what
drugs do to you huh she was
young and happy
don't do drugs go to the one top left
with uh seth rogen
tablet dude that's okay
anyway she was young and hot that's the
first time i saw her
but
not a-lister at all
and certainly her looks are an a-lister
at this point no but but i have a point
here let's go to johnny depp's
um
movie movie greatest movies he's ever
done i'm a movie buffer okay so this
guy's pirates of the caribbean but he's
older than her so he's had more time too
truly yeah for sure sure
edward but that's very versatile he's
arguably the most versatile actor of
characterization okay yeah power to the
caribbean love it eddie scissorhands
amazing sweeney todd that's another uh
my brother's favorite movie
who who made that movie
uh timber another timber
movie
another pirates of the caribbean charlie
and the chocolate factory great the
tourist i actually like that secret
window
keep going prior to the caribbean
another one dead man's chest alice in
wonderland great one chocolate
finding neverland which i think is an
underrated great movie what finding
neverland yes i love that if you make
kelly cry it's obviously a great movie
it made me cry
it's really good parts of the character
how many pirates the goddamn caribbean
are there
five wait they're six okay i think six
they're brave not anymore keep going
cry baby ironically great movie that was
from i want to say late 1990s sleepy
hollow
the ninth gate
rango the libertine
public enemies gangster movies
celebrity icon actor yep
be the man
you have
your pick of the litter and i don't mean
to be crass you can get with
by the way you're a certified stud good
looking like go to him and cry baby pull
that up dude look what this guy looked
like in krabi you could be with any girl
you want yeah you pick amber heard i
assume because she's attractive
okay
not so much because she's an amazing
actress
he picks her
b-list actress
right b-list actress
attractive not supermodel hot
there's a storyline there
and i'm trying to put my finger on it
but
an a-list hollywood actor icon can have
his entire
empire brought down
by just being in a toxic crazy
relationship with a crazy girl she must
have they must have had amazing sex or
something there was something that was
just like i got to keep coming back to
this because that's i think when it
comes to relationships like that what
what makes that what is the is it like a
psychiatry thing that you could tell me
yeah what makes you keep going back to
that what me what makes me keep going to
this is i'm hearing rolo in my voice
that he is a
he is a
high value beta male
he's blue pill
high value
like if you're a red pill man meaning
like again this is rollo giving him a
shout out he's gonna say i'm the
freaking man in this relationship
what i say goes if not you can hit the
door and go hang out with whatever
b-list actor you want you're in my world
johnny depp world and this is this is
how it goes there's no
you know
none of this games are being played here
understand who you're working with by
the way you know who probably has these
exact same conversations
leonardo dicaprio
okay so maybe he's one of the few guys
as big and sexier and a hot commodity as
big as johnny depp right how many can
you put on that list
right
he just goes through women like all
right cool cool cool it's not working
out great love you peace bye
never domestic violence issues never
drama leo must have a great work like a
filter
red pill i understand my role as the
alpha male you get in line i lead you
follow this how it goes
something with johnny depp is off
something he wasn't
man enough to say like baby
you're living in my house
these are my rules we can have fun we
can get crazy but at the end of the day
like i'm the leader here yeah i believe
most girls are going to say
yes sir mr depp
most girls am i wrong on that natalia
um no i think you're right i think i
especially like
in his caliber
i would understand a lot of women saying
like
yes i will follow you now
i do think because amber
does have a little bit of credibility in
the celebrity world not as much
um i think that gave her or made her
feel like
you know she also
is coming in from like that masculine
side like no i'm not gonna listen to you